astronomers have found dozens of
potentially habitable planets outside of
our solar system
that's dozens of chances to discover the
first alien life or you know plenty of
places we could park our first
interstellar colonies but with so many
options how do we know which is best you
might think that most earth-like planets
should be at the top of our list after
all we've got everything we need water
land and atmosphere and trillions of
life forms lapping it all up but
according to a small group of
researchers there are bigger and better
planets out there they're called super
Earth's super Earths maybe some of the
most common planets in our galaxy since
2009 the Kepler space telescope has
discovered about 4,000 exoplanets 30% of
them are super-earths and a few percent
of those super Earth's orbit within
their host stars habitable zone
that's the Goldilocks zone where the
planet's surface is just the right
temperature for liquid water not too
cold not too hot now there's a chance
some of these super Earths aren't rocky
worlds like Earth the larger ones could
be made out of mostly hydrogen and
helium gas like Jupiter and Saturn which
would not be very hospitable for life
but the reality is astronomers are still
gathering details as more data comes in
so in the meantime let's explore what
life on a rocky habitable super-earths
might be like liquid water is just the
start
these planets can be almost double
Earth's radius and up to 10 times more
massive and all that extra mass is what
researchers think could really make
super Earths
the perfect home that's because more
massive planets have a stronger
gravitational pull
super Earths Kepler 20 B for example is
nearly double the size of Earth and it's
10 times more massive
this makes its surface gravity almost
three times stronger that stronger
gravity means that the planet can hold
on to more air molecules and form a
thicker atmosphere which is great for
protecting against harmful space
radiation
it also means mountains and hills would
erode a lot faster leaving a relatively
flatter surface compared to Earth now
that might sound boring but scientists
think this could actually spawned dozens
of shallow islands all across the planet
those in turn could be the perfect place
for life to form and evolve just as
biodiversity in Earth's oceans is
richest in shallow waters near
coastlines such an archipelago world
might be enormous ly advantageous to
life there's just one problem leaving
this tropical paradise would be
extremely difficult the escape velocity
on Kepler 20 B is more than double
compared to Earth's which means either
Rockets would need more fuel to reach
their destinations like for example a
mission similar to the Apollo moon
landing would require twice the amount
of fuel or Rockets would have to carry
only a fraction of the payload for
instance
SpaceX's Falcon Heavy can launch 50,000
kilograms of payload into Earth's orbit
whereas it could only launch 40
kilograms into orbit around a super
earth like Kepler 20 B that's about the
weight of a German Shepard suffice it to
say leaving a super-earth would be a far
greater challenge but if it looked like
this what you really want to say goodbye
we'll never know for sure until we visit
one what questions do you have about
space leave your queries in the comments
below and thanks for watching